from little children to the very old
they fled from Islamic state and wound
up here 10 kilometers south of Baghdad
1,400 families this is a typical Iraqi
refugee camp hygiene is lacking and that
affects the weakest first oh dear my son
has lost his hair well I think I am worn
out our children all have severe
diarrhea dumb bottom a makeshift
doctor's office full of children but
just one physician he has to look after
about 80 children a day it's all
makeshift nothing else is possible often
there's no medicine for the various
illnesses which the children contract in
the camp a lot of cases of scabies which
is a skinny jean due to infection by
some parasite and Douglas came many
children have respiratory diseases
besides a lack of medicine there's
little medical equipment frustrating
conditions for the doctor and his
patients after the diagnosis there's
often little he can do to help an empty
container is the hospital and that is
exactly what the refugees need this
family has a relatively spacious tent
but that is about all they have a mini
kitchen a pair of mattresses no table
they just have to make do well there's
always jakku so as la McStay drove us
out they put us under pressure the
problem has gotten worse crime has
gotten worse under is these is people
have stolen our dignity our children
have no future what should they do we
have been driven out now all we know is
exhaustion and illness
ahead double a lot up two children from
the family died here in the refugee camp
south of Baghdad the doctor couldn't get
the medicine that would have saved their
lives